dear Victor thanks so much for the
invitation
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen it is an honor to address once
again Euro annual galadina
and to celebrate with you the 50th
birthday of the U.S National Academy of
Medicine
the academy was born to provide
independent advice to American
institutions
today
your voice Echoes all over the world
since the start of the pandemic I saw
you shape the global response to covet
19.
you have been a trusted source of
expertise for the G20
for U.N agencies for Global Health
actors
and yes also for us in the European
Union
I remember very vividly one evening in
mid-march 2020
the early weeks on the pandemic when I
received a phone call from my dear
friend Victor Zhao
Victor told me
the pandemic called for Global Response
and Europe must take a leading role
and since then we have tried to shape
This Global Response together
we worked very closely with you dear
Victor
to accelerate the development of covet
vaccines
and to create a global facility to share
vaccines with low-income countries
that is how the ACT accelerator and
Kovacs were born
and immediately afterwards we Europeans
started preparations for the first
Global Health Summit in Rome
with the ambitious goal of making
covid-19 the last pandemic
it was a collective Global mobilization
which is bearing important fruit
the principles that we agreed in Rome
are guiding Global action to this day
last month for instance the World Bank
launched the new Financial intermediary
fund
for pandemic prevention preparedness and
response
the European Commission in the United
States are its two largest contributors
because we believe that supporting low
and middle income countries
is not only the right thing to do but in
our own strategic interest
I know that you at the National Academy
of Medicine share this View
you have warned us about the dangers of
an unbalanced geographic distribution of
vaccine production centers
your latest paper on learning the
lessons of covid-19 published last month
is crystal clear about that
Europe has exported roughly 2.5 billion
covered vaccines to the rest of the
world
we are by far the world's largest
exporter of vaccines
and we are proud of this
but we also know that this is not
sustainable
so today
we're working with our friends in Africa
and Latin America
to support them to produce their own
mRNA vaccines
our goal is to Foster local production
with world-class technology
so as you can see we take your advice
very seriously
because this is what politics should
always do
listen to science
and you can count on Europe to always
put science at the heart of its policy
making
just like we count on you to keep
providing your invaluable advice not
just to America
but to the whole world
ladies and gentlemen today we celebrate
50 years of achievements for the
National Academy of Medicine
including your latest success yet
another Nobel Prize for one of your
members
Professor Caroline bertazzi has
literally invented a new branch of
chemistry allowing for instance to
develop new therapies against cancer
so let me congratulate her
and thank the entire National Academy of
Medicine community
for pushing once again the boundaries of
human knowledge
happy birthday National Academy of
Medicine
and thank you so much for inviting me on
this happy occasion